let's see if we can apply some of our
new tools to solve some line integrals
so let's say we have a line integral
along a closed curve I'm going to define
the path in a second of x squared plus y
squared times DX plus 2 XY 2 X Y times
dy and then our curve C our curve C is
going to be defined by the
parameterization X is equal to a cosine
of T and Y is equal to sine of T and
this is valid for T between 0 between 0
& 2 pi so this is essentially a circle a
unit circle in the XY plane and we know
how to solve these but let's see if we
can use some of our discoveries in the
last couple of videos to maybe simplify
this this process so the first thing you
might say hey Jesus how is it you know
this looks like a line integral but you
have a DX and dy I don't see a dot d R
here it's not clear to me that this is
some type of even a vector line integral
I don't see any vectors what I want to
do first and the reason why I wanted to
show you this example is just to show
you that this is just another form of
writing really a vector line integral
and to show you that you just have to
realize if I have some R of T this is
our curve let's I won't even write these
functions in their scores I'm just going
to write it's X of T times I plus y of T
times J we've seen several videos now
that we can write dr/dt as being equal
to DX DT times i plus dy/dt times J
we've seen this multiple times and we've
seen multiple times we want to get the
differential dr we could just multiply
everything times DT and normally I just
put a DT here and a DT there and get rid
of this DT but if you multiply
everything times DT if you view this as
the differentials as actual numbers you
can multiply and normally you can treat
them like that then you just get rid of
all of the dt so dr
you could imagine is equal to DX times
the unit vector I plus dy times the unit
vector J so put that aside and you might
already see a pattern here so if we
define if we define our vector field f f
of X Y as being equal to x squared plus
y squared x squared plus y squared I
plus 2 X Y J what is this thing what is
this thing over here well what is f dot
dr going to be dot products you just
multiply the corresponding components of
our vectors and then add them up so it's
going to be if you take this F and dot
it with that dr you're going to get the
I component x squared plus y squared
times that DX times DX plus I'll do it
in the pink again plus the Y component
the J component 2xy times that dy that's
the dot product and notice this thing
right here that thing right here is
identical to that thing right there so
our line integral just to put it in a
form that we're familiar with this is
the same exact thing as the line
integral over this curve over this curve
see this closed curve C of this F maybe
I'll write in that magenta color or that
actually gives more of a purple or pink
color F dot this dr that's what this
line integral is is just a different way
of writing and now that you see it in
the future if you see it in kind of this
differential form you'll immediately
know okay there's one vector field that
this is its X component this is its Y
component dotting with dr which it where
there's this is this is the X component
of dr the i component and this is the y
component the J component of the dr so
you immediately know what the vector
field is that we're taking the line
integral of it's this is
X that's the Y now let's ask ourselves a
question is f is f conservative so is f
is f equal to the gradient of some
scalar field we'll call it capital F is
this the case so let's zoom it is and
see if we can solve for we can solve for
a scalar field whose gradient really is
f then we know that f is conservative
and then if F is conservative and this
is the whole reason we want to do it
that means that any closed loop any line
integral over a closed curve of F is
going to be equal to zero and we'd be
done so if we can show this then the
answer to this question or this question
is going to be zero we don't even have
to mess with the cosine of T's and the
sine of T's and all of that and actually
we don't even have to take anti
derivatives so let's see if we can find
an F whose gradient is equal to that
right there whose gradient is equal to
that right there so in order for F
sprayed it to be that that means that
the partial derivative of our capital F
with respect to X has got to be equal to
that right there right it's got to be
equal to it's got to be equal to x
squared plus y squared and it also tells
us that the partial derivative of
capital F the partial derivative of
capital F with respect to Y has got to
be equal to 2xy it's got to be equal to
2xy and just as a review you know if I
have the gradient of any function of any
scalar field is equal to the partial of
F with respect to X times I plus the
partial of capital F with respect to Y
times J so that's why I'm just pattern
matching I'm just saying well gee if if
this is the gradient of that then this
must be that which I wrote down right
here and this must be that which I wrote
down here so let's see if I can find an
F that satisfies both of these
constraints so we can just take the
antiderivative with respect to X on both
sides and if we take the antiderivative
with respect to X on both sides remember
you just treat Y like a
or y-squared like a constant is just a
number so then we could say that F is
equal to the antiderivative of x squared
is X to the third over three X to the
third over 3 and then the antiderivative
of Y squared remember with respect to X
so you just treat like a number that
could just be the number K or this could
be the number five so there's just going
to be that times X so plus X times y
squared and then there could be some
function of Y here so plus some I don't
know I'll call it you know G of Y
because there could have been some
function of Y here when you take if it's
a pure function of Y when you take the
derivative or the partial with respect
to X this would have disappeared so it
would reappear when we take the
antiderivative and let me just to be
just to be clear let me make it clear
that F F is going to be a function of x
and y so this we just took the I guess
you could say the antiderivative this
right 2x let's see if we take the
antiderivative respect to Y and then we
can reconcile the two so based on this f
of XY f of XY is going to have to look
like so let's take the antiderivative
with respect to Y here so remember you
just treat X like it's just some number
it could be a K it could be an M it
could be a 5 it's just some number so if
X is just some the antiderivative to Y
is y squared and if X is just a number
there the antiderivative this with
respect to Y is just going to be X Y
squared don't believe me take the
partial of this with respect to Y treat
X like a constant you'll get 2 times XY
and then you with no exponent there and
of course we took the antiderivative
with respect to X there might be some
function of X here we were just basing
it off of that information now given
that we this information says f of XY is
going to have to look something like
this this information tells us F of XY
is going to have to look something like
that let's see if there is an f of XY
that looks like both of them essentially
so let's see we have on this one we have
XY squared here we have an XY squared
there so good that looks good and then
over here we have an F of
we have something that's a pure function
of X and here we have something that is
a pure function of X so these two things
could be the same thing and then here we
have a pure function of Y that might be
there but it didn't really show up
anywhere over here so we could just say
hey that probably that's that's going to
be zero zero is a pure function of Y you
could have something called G of Y is
equal to zero and then we get that F
capital f of X Y is equal to X to the
third over 3 plus X Y squared and the
gradient of this is going to be equal to
F and we've already established that but
just to hit the point home let's take
the gradient of it just so you don't
believe this little stuff that I did
right there let's take the gradient the
gradient of F is equal to and sometimes
people put a little vector there because
you're getting a vector out of it you
get a little vector on top of that
gradient sign the gradient of F is going
to be what the partial of this with
respect to x times I so the partial of
this with respect to X the derivative
here is 3 divided by 3 is 1 so it's just
x squared plus the derivative of this
with respect to X is y squared times I
plus the partial with respect to Y well
the partial with respect to Y of this is
0 partial with respect to Y of this is 2
X Y or 2 XY to the first so it's 2xy
times J and this is exactly equal to F
RF that we wrote up there so we've
established we've established that F can
definitely be written it F is definitely
the gradient of some potential scalar
function there so F is conservative is
conservative and that tells us that this
closed loop integral line integral of F
is going to be equal to 0 and we are
done we could even ignore the actual
parameter ization of the path